zfte live herzlich willkommen euch allen
zu unserem wöchentlichen Ukrain Update
ja und die neue Woche begann zunächst
mit einem Erfolg für die ukrainische
Luftwaffe zwei hochausgerüstete
russische Flugzeuge konnten von der
Ukraine ins Visier genommen werden eins
davon wurde wohl nach Angaben
abgeschossen das andere schwer
beschädigt und es ist ein Verlust für
Russland denn diese Flugzeuge wurden zur
Aufklärung und Identifikation von Zielen
in der Ukraine genutzt der Kremmel
äußerte sich bislang nicht zum Schaden
ebenso wenig zu seinen Verlusten beim
Personal und Geschütz viel mehr bleiben
die russischen Streitkräfte momentan im
Angriffsmodus Drohnen und Luftangriffe
vor allem auf zivile Einrichtungen gibt
es in den Regionen um hson harkiv avdka
und krinki die Ukraine gerät zunehmend
in die Defensive und hat Probleme neue
Munition für die Soldaten anzuschaffen
wir wollen bei ZDF heute live deshalb
mal in die einzelnen Brennpunkte schauen
entlang der Front von Süden nach Norden
und Fragen ja ob Putin nach Putins
angriffplänen und ob ihm die Mittel
fehlen für weitere offensiven und dazu
sprechen wir gleich mit unserer
Korrespondentin Anne Brühl die sich
aktuell in Kiev befindet und mit unserem
heutigen Militärexperten Oberst des
österreichischen Bundesheeres Markus
Reisner wie immer gerne gesehen eure
Fragen Meinungen und Kommentare die ihr
uns über die Kommentarspalten schicken
könnt oder auch gerne via Mail zunächst
wollen wir euch unseren Militärexperten
des Tages heute vorstellen einige kennen
ihn vielleicht schon er ist nicht zum
ersten Mal bei ZF heute live Markus
Reisner heißt er und ein kurzes Roundup
von ihm hat an Kathrine Heger
vorbereitet
militäranalytiker Historiker und aktiver
Soldat Oberst Markus Reisner analysiert
den russischen Angriffskrieg auf die
Ukraine seit dessen Beginn Reisner
leitet seit September 2022 die
Forschungs und Entwicklungsabteilung an
der Theresianischen Militärakademie in
Wien und ist Kommandant des
österreichischen
gardebataillons zuvor von 2004 bis 2013
war Reisner Teil einer Spezialeinheit
des österreichischen Bundesheers in
dieser Zeit nahm er an verschiedenen
Auslandseinsätzen Teil etwa in Mali der
Zentralafrikanischen Republik Bosnien
und herzegoovwiina Kosovo Chad und
Afghanistan und er ist uns heute aus der
Maria Theresien Kaserne in Wien
zugeschaltet einen schönen guten Abend
zu Ihnen Herr
Reisner guten Abend liebe Grüße a Wien
lassen s uns erstmal mit den aktuellen
Meldungen beginnen Herr Reisner zum
asofschen mehrchauen der Verlust zweier
russischer Flugzeuge sind laut
ukrainischer Luftwaffe der jüngste
Erfolg wie sehr hat das Russland
geschadet ja wir haben hier ganz klar
die Aussage von no general saluschni
dass es gelungen sein soll zumindest
eines dieser beiden Flugzeuge
abzuschießen eine sogenannte der A50
dieses Flugzeug ist deswegen
bedeutungsvoll weil es zur Früherkennung
vor allem von möglichen Zielen auf
ukrainischer Seite für die russische
Seite dient es ist quasi wie eine
fliegende radarplattform zu betrachten
und das zweite Flugzeug ist eine
sogenannte il22m eine fliegende
Kommandozentrale nach den jetzt
vorliegenden Berichten soll es so
gewesen sein dass es zumindest mit Boden
luftsystemen der fliegeabwehr oder
möglicherweise auch mit der
luftluftsysteme gelungen ist diese A50
abzuschießen es gibt hier noch keine
offizielle Bestätigung des Kremel aber
in den sozialen Netzwerken auch auf
russischer Seite wird dieser Verlust
diskutiert und besprochen das heiß der
dürfte sehr wahrscheinlich passiert sind
obwohl wir noch keine Bilder eines Frags
vorliegen haben anders ist es bei dem
zweiten Flugzeug bei dieser il22m hier
gibt es tatsächlich zumindest zwei
Bilder dieses Heckleitwerk dieses
Flugzeuges zeigen das offensichtlich
durchlöchert worden ist in einer Art und
Weise wie es typisch ist für
fliegabwehrsysteme und damit kann man
davon ausgehen dass es zumindest
gelungen ist dieses Flugzeug zu
beschädigen das Besondere an beiden
Systemen ist dass sie nur in einer
begrenzten Stückzahl verfügbar sind z.B
dies A50 hier nimmt man an dass ca zwei
Handvoll verfügbar sind von denen immer
eine Handvoll im Einsatz ist und rotiert
und da bedeutet natürlich dieser
Abschuss seh wohl eine signifikante
Verringerung der Fähigkeit der russiser
Seite und sie dürfen nicht vergessen die
Russen sind jetzt gezwungen bis zur
Klärung der Umstände was hat also diese
Ursache des Abschusses mit sich gebracht
gezwungen ihre Kräfte zurückzuziehen in
der Luft um zu vermeiden dass es zu
weiteren Abschüssen kommt die russische
Seite hat ein narrativ in den Raum
gestellt dass es durch Friendly Fire
also durch eigene Kräfte abgeschossen
wäre das scheint aber eher
unwahrscheinlich da beide Flugzeuge das
in einer groß auseinanderliegenden
Distanz getroffen worden sind mhm also
im Luftraum müssen Sie wie Sie sagen
erstmal die Kräfte zurückziehen aber am
Boden da ist Angriff angesagt wie man in
den letzten Tagen beobachten konnte und
auch Meldungen aus der vergangenen Nacht
dass es wieder ordentliche Luftangriffe
gab 33 drohen und zwei Raketen wurden da
auf die Ukraine abgefeuert ähm die
ukrainische Seite beklagt schon seit
längerem dass es an Munition fehlt das
hat vitaliie klitschku jetzt auch noch
mal bekräftigt es gibt da enorme
Defizite und er sagt es ge aktuell einen
wahnsinnsdruck von russischer Seite
trotz ja Verluste und Verschleiß die es
ja bei russischer Seite gibt
beispielsweise eben jetzt mit diesen
zwei Flugzeugen die es jetzt nicht mehr
gibt auf russischer Seite scheint das
ganze ja doch noch zu funktionieren
Kriegsmaterial scheint ausreichend da zu
sein ja das ist das Dilemma wir sehen
also diese Ereignisse und diese Berichte
die zum Teil spektakuläre Erfolge mit
sich bringen wie dieser Abschuss von
diesen A50 und man hat also den Eindruck
dass es für die ukrainische Seite gut
läuft tatsächlich ist es aber so wenn
man es so ins Detail geht auf der
strategischen operativen und taktischen
Ebene sieht man dass tatsächlich die
Ukraine in der Defensive ist und
Russland in der Offensive unter anderem
ist es darauf zurückzuführen dass
Russland es geschafft hat vor im letzten
Jahr seinen militärischen industriellen
Komplex anzukurbeln und die
munitionsproduktion signifikant zu
erhöhen und zwar jene m die auf den
verschiedenen Ebenen eingesetzt ist das
heißt z.B auf der strategischen Ebene
ist es vor allem der Einsatz von marslow
Körpern und diesen von dem irang
gelieferten Drohnen die Russland jetzt
selbst produziert man nimmt an dass
Russland in der Lage ist im Monat ca 100
marsflugkörper und ballistische Raketen
zu produzieren und ca 350 Dronen das
heißt das sind 450 in einem Monat
verfügbaren Angriffsmittel die natürlich
von ukrainische Seite bekämpft werden
müssen durch fliegabwehrsysteme und
durch die Munition dazu auf operativ und
taktische Ebene ist vor allem der
Einsatz der Artillerie der den ukrainen
große Probleme bereitet man nimmt an
dass Russland letztes Jahr ca 2
Millionen Stück Artilleriegranaten vom
Kaliber 122 und 152 mm erzeugt hat dazu
kamen noch die Lieferung von einer
Million artilleriggranaten aus Nordkorea
und das bedeutet dass jetzt zur Zeit
wieder das Verhältnis pro Tag in etwa
ist 2000 Schuss auf ukrainischer Seite
zu 10.000 Schuss auf russischer Seite
und da sieht man natürlich dass hier
sich das Gleichgewicht zu Ungunsten der
Ukraine entwickelt wenn die Ukraine
nicht weiter massiv un gestützt wird um
hier entgegenehalten zu können tja und
da bleibt da kommt direkt auch die erste
Frage von unserem Zuschauer space Cowboy
auf Youtube welche Waffensysteme könnten
die Länder der EU kurzfristig an die
Ukraine liefern was ist da noch machbar
gibt es einen mittelfristigen Plan die
Ukraine nachhaltig zu unterstützen was
glauben
Sie dazu muss man sich ja ansehen wie
die Strategie der Ukraine im Moment sich
darstellt und die Ukraine hat da zu Ende
letzten Jahres kund getan dass sie quasi
von der Offensive in die Defensive gehen
möchte Defensive bedeutet dass Halten
des gewonnenen Geländes und vor allem
das konsolidierens in der Tiefe des
Landes das heißt der Schutz der
kritischen Infrastruktur der Schutz des
Ukrainisch militärisch industriellen
komplexes um im Laufe dieses Jahres
quasi in der Lage zu sein eigene
Rüstungsproduktion wieder hochzufahren
und damit sind wir bei entsprechend
prioritätenreihung und das bedeutet am
Beginn vor allem das Senden von weiteren
fliegerbystemen von weiteren fliegerb
Batterien ob das jetzt irsd oder PE od
oder ähnliches ist und der entsprechend
Munition damit dieses erste strategische
Ziel erreicht werden kann in weiterer
Folge dann alle jene Systeme die es auch
für die Ukraine möglich machen die
Russen an empfindlichen Stellen zu
treffen das heißt es werden bodenboden
oder luftbodensysteme mit entsprechender
Reichweite mit dem man dann in der Lage
ist z.B logistikpunkte der russischen
Armee oder auch Kommandostrukturen
anzugreifen der Westen hat ja zumindest
heute Nachmittag eine Antwort schon mal
rausgeschickt das kam als einmeldung die
NATO plant im Februar ja das größte
Manöver seit dem Kalten Krieg 90.000
Soldaten sollen dann da im Einsatz sein
man will ja den worst case sage ich mal
Proben sofern Russland eventuell
natoterritorium angreift wie man sich da
verteidigt und welcher Antwort man da
entgegensetzt heißt es man will man
wolle damit Putin abschrecken da stellt
sich dann natürlich die Frage wenn solch
ein Szenario eintritt oder wenn jetzt
erstmal das ganze geprobt wird
beeindruckt das Putin oder ist es gar
abschreckend für
ihn ja diese Übung ist natürlich ein
wichtiges Zeichen der NATO gegenüber
Russland um Russland verstehen zu geben
dass man nicht bereit ist zu en dass es
tatsächlich zu einem angff
natoterritorium kommen würde im
Wesentlichen sind hier vier Faktoren die
relevant sind einerseits der Faktor
Kraft man sieht hier die Menge von
90.000 Allierten Soldaten zusammen also
sehr hohe Zahl die quasi über Europa
verteilt eingesetzt werden und man zeigt
auch dass man quasi diesen Raum vom
Nordeuropa bis in den Süden hinunter
beherrschen kann bzw dass es möglich ist
aus den USA zusätzliche Kräfte
heranzuführen und das und damit sind wir
beim Faktor Z das dritten Faktor in sehr
kurzer und relevanter Zeit das ist man
ist verlegefähig man kann also die
Frasch auch reagieren für den Fall dass
Russland etwas unternimmt und der vierte
das vierte Element ist natürlich der
Faktor Information hier geht's vor allem
ganz klar darum auch im Informationsraum
dominant aufzutreten diesen Raum nicht
der russischen Seite zu überlassen
sondern auch zu zeigen und auch den
europäischen Bevölkerung und der NATO
Mitgliedern zu zeigen wir sind in der
Lage in kurzer Zeit massive Kräfte
aufzubieten um hier Wasi auch unseren
Bündnispartnern beizustehen im Fall
eines Angriffes wir wollen heute Abend
bei ZF live in die einzelnen Brennpunkte
in die Region schauen und wollen mal im
Süden anfangen Herr Reisener schauen wir
nach herson zunächst die Region war
russisch besetzt wurde vor einem Jahr
von der Ukraine
wieder befreit und ist scheinbar nun ein
Ort den die Russen verstärkt wieder
angreifen da ist in dieser Woche erst
wurden da wieder zahlreiche Wohngebäude
bei Luftangriffen zerstört hat man
gelesen was für eine Strategie verfolgt
Putin denn da
jetzt ja das Süden der Front da hat im
Wesentlich in zwei Bereiche die für die
Russen interessant sind einerseits ist
es das Industriezentrum kerson wo ist es
lich einige Betriebe gibt die für die
Rüstung der ukrainischen Streitkräfte
produzieren und hier versucht man ganz
gezielt mit der marsflohkörpern mit
ballistischen Raketen mit iranischen
drohen diese Ziele zu treffen und da bei
der Abwehr von diesen einfliegenden
marschflugörern kommt es dann zu
Abschüssen wo zum Teil auch diese
drümmer in den bewohnten Gebieten
heruntergehen oder aufgrund einer
ungenauen eines ungenauen Einsatzes der
russischen Raketen dass diese quasi in
den Wohngebieten herunterkomen das ist
da eine Versuch das ist auch ähnlich in
hakiv oder auch in anderen Städten wie
z.B in Kiev vor allem am ostuf des
nepers das zweite was im Süden
interessant ist ist natürlich die
Situation in dem Brückenkopf bei grinki
tatsächlich gibt es eigentlich hier vier
Brückenköpfe entlang des nepers und die
Situation ist die dass die Ukraine hier
versucht vor allem auch zu zeigen dass
es ihr möglich ist auch Momentum
aufrechtzuhalten durch den Einsatz ihrer
Kräfte sind hier vier Brigaden der
ukrainischen Marines die eingesetzt sind
die quasi hier rotieren und dort
eingesetzt sind das Dilemma besteht
darin dass die Witterungsverhältnisse
mittlerweile sehr prekär sind es ist so
dass der ne beginnt zuzufrieren in dem
sum Gebiet auch die kleinen Flussläufe
frieren zu es ist kaum mehr möglich
diese Kräfte zu versorgen und damit
spitzt sich die Situation zu und
Russland ist momentan gerade dabei
grinke langsam wieder zurückzuobern und
wir sehen jetzt natürlich dass es quasi
hier dieser Kampf unter dies
mitterungsbedingungen sehr schwierig ist
und dass hier die Ukraine gezwungen ist
die logistische Versorgung so gut wie
möglich aufrecht zu halten wenn Sie
diesen Brückenkopf halten möchte und
nicht aufgeben möchte mhm da stehen die
Zeichen scheinbar auf Angriff Jan fragt
wie realistisch ist es dass Russland
sich aus der Ukraine zurückzieht bei
diesem Bild dann wohl er
unwahrscheinlich
oder das ist korrekt da wenn auch hier
man sich anhört was ukrainische
offizielle sagen nehmen wir nur die Zahl
der verfügbaren Kräfte auf russischer
Seite man geht davon aus dass Russland
ca 462 000 Soldaten in der Ukraine im
Einsatz hat dazu kommen noch 35 Soldaten
der rosgardia also der Besatzungstruppen
man NMT an dass Russland in der Lage ist
pro Tag zwischen 1000 und 11 neue
Rekruten wasasi die als
vertragsbedienstet übernommen werden in
die Streitkräfte zu übernehmen das
gleicht in jeden Fall die Verluste aus
die auch von ukrainischer Seite
angegeben werden und das bedeutet dass
man eigentlich um das Doppelte wenn
nicht Zweieinhalbfache mehr an Kräften
verfügbar hat als am Beginn des Krieges
und Russland wie sie völlig richtig
gesagt haben ist im Angriffsmodus wir
haben jetzt den zweiten Winter die
zweite Winteroffensive die Russen
versuchen an verschiedenen Stellen an
vielen Stellen gleichzeitig anzugreifen
Rücken Meter für Meter vor das Ziel ist
es aber vor allem die Ukraine zu zwingen
ihre kostbarenreserven auszuspielen und
einzusetzen und die Absicht der Russen
ist es quasi soweit weiterzumachen bis
aus ihrer Sicht man quasi die Ukraine so
in die Defensive gezwungen hat dass es
möglicherweise zu dem massiven
Durchbruch kommt der sich aber momentan
auf keinen Fall abzeichnet Herr Reisner
vielen Dank bis hierhin wir reden gleich
noch ausführlicher weiter wollen aber
mal zunächst in die Ukraine schalten zu
unserer Korrespondentin Anne Brühl und
mit ihr ein Stückchen weiter nördlich
schauen im Nordosten das ist nämlich
ebenfalls eine ja derzeit hart umkämpfte
Region unter anderem der Ort kopjansk
zählt mit dazu und ja erst letzten
Sommer Anne ein schön guten Abend zu dir
warst du ja in dieser Region die jetzt
aktuell wieder stark umkämpft ist was
hörst du in der Ukraine wie angespannt
ist da die
Lage ja die Lage um kopjan ist sehr
angespannt die Russen haben da ja im
Spätsommer versucht so einer Art dritte
Front zu errichten kopjansk liimann
haben da in diesen Abschnitt 100.000
Soldaten verlegt kopjansk liegt ja im
Osten der Region hakiv war gleich zu
Beginn des Kriegs von den Russen besetzt
die Ukrainer konnten kopjansk und
weitere Gebiete in der Region zurück
erobern damals in dieser herbstoffensive
22 kupjansk ist also ein Symbol
trächtiger Ort womöglich auch für die
Russen womöglich auch gerade in dieser
Zeit und womöglich versuchen Sie deshalb
mit aller Macht davor zustoßen ich war
im August zum letzten Mal dort da gab es
schon evakuierungsbefehle da lag die
Stadt das Zentrum unter ständigem
Artilleriebeschuss die Front war sehr
nah es gab immer noch ein paar tausend
Menschen die da ausgeharrt haben die
Gründe sind immer dieselben das sind
alte Menschen mit kleinen Pensionen mit
wenig Geld die nicht wissen wo sie hin
sollen manchmal haben die kranke
Angehörige zu versorgen die nicht
transportfähig sind die bleiben also
dort und
das
es gibt jetzt einen neuen
Evakuierungsbefehl für zwei Ortschaften
am der Peripherie von kupjansk unter
anderem auch kindra schifska im
Nordwesten und das ist möglicherweise
ein Zeichen dass die Russen dabei sind
so eine Art Klammer um kopianz zu legen
und das wäre dann kein gutes Zeichen für
die Zivilbevölkerung dort mhm wir haben
es gerade schon mit Herrn Reisner
thematisiert das letzte Nacht gab es
wieder neue Großangriffe aus der Luft
seitens Russland auf die Ukraine die
ukrainische Luftwaffe hat das ganze auch
bestätigt und laut eigenen Angaben 22
von 33 russischen Drohnen abgeschossen
radekiv wurde mit 2 S300 Raketen
beschossen und dann sieht man dann
tagsüber erstmal das Ausmaß der
Zerstörung das sind meistens Wohnhäuser
die da von den Russen zerstört werden
wie geht's der Zivilbevölkerung damit
aktuell ja in rakif geht's der
Zivilbevölkerung schlecht weil sie seit
Tagen eigentlich Wochen
sehr heftig angegriffen werden es gibt
darüber hinaus auch die Befürchtung dass
die Russen noch einmal versuchen könnten
auf die Stadt vorzurücken die Stadt zu
erobern das haben sie zu Beginn des
Kriegs mal versucht da standen R
russische Soldaten in den Außenbezirken
von hakiv das ist ja die zweitgrößte
Stadt der Ukraine das ist ihnen aber
nicht gelogen die Soldaten haben sich
dann zurückgezogen aber Fakt ist jeden
Tag eigentlich wird
hakif mit S300 Raketen beschossen das
sind eigentlich Luftabwehrraketen die
Russen nutzen sie aber da quasi als
bodenbodenraketen schießen sie ab von
unmittelbar hinter der Grenze zur
Ukraine in der Region belgorot das sind
so 60 80 Kilometer maximal bis ins
Stadtzentrum von hakif die vorwahnzeit
für die Bevölkerung ist oft wahnsinnig
kurz es dauert ungefähr maximal 2
Minuten vom Abschuss bis zum Einschlag
einer solchen Rakete das heißt manchmal
ist noch nicht mal der Luftalarm
ausgelöst sondern es gibt direkt
Explosionen im Zentrum dieser Stadt du
hast es gesagt es sind immer wieder
Wohnhäuser betroffen Hotels medizinische
Zentren
ich habe Kontakt mit einer Frau in hakiv
mit der ich mir dann auch schreib die
mir jetzt in einer dieser letzten Nächte
schrieb sie ist Gott sei Dank okay aber
es ist sehr laut das ist die ukrainische
Umschreibung für heftige Angriffe laute
Explosionen in der Nähe sie hat mir aber
auch geschrieben allmählich wird es zu
vielere mich noch an das letzte
Interview was wir beide hier geführt
haben an bei ZDF heute live da hast du
zumindest noch so ein kleinen
Hoffnungsschimmer davon erzählt dass du
auch positive Stimmungen eingefangen
hast von Menschen die trotz allem
kämpferisch sich dem ganz
entgegenstellen jetzt mit Blick auf das
frisch gestartete neue Jahr und mit
diesen neuen heftigen Angriffen
Russlands ist die Stimmung ein bisschen
pessimistischer geworden oder sind die
Ukrainerinnen Ukrainer weiterhin doch
noch
positiv na ja das ist glaube ich beides
also ich nehme schon zu Beginn dieses
neuen Jahres eine sehr gedrückte
pessimistische Stimmung war ähm vor
genau einem Jahr war das noch völlig
anders da waren viele Ukrainer davon
überzeugt dass die dieser Krieg bald zu
Ende gehen könnte das glaubt
mittlerweile hier wirklich niemand mehr
ähm es gibt die Sorge wegen anderer
weltweiter Krisen dass die Welt ein
bisschen auch die Ukraine und diesen
Krieg hier vergessen könnte dass die
Unterstützung aufhören könnte und
gleichzeitig erlebe ich aber nach wie
vor diese Entschlossenheit die Menschen
die sagen wir haben gar keine andere
Alternative wir müssen diesen Krieg
gewinnen die Alternative die sehen sie
ja hier auch im Land denn fast ein
Fünftel der Ukraine genauer gesagt 18 %
sind ja immer noch von russischen
Truppen besetzt aus diesen besetzten
Gebieten gibt es Berichte von
zwangsrussifizierung Gewalt Folter
verschleppte Kinder die
Ukrainer wissen also was auf dem Spiel
steht und die Menschen mit denen ich
rede die sagen wir wollen in einer
freien Ukraine in einer demokratischen
Ukraine Leben und in einer in einem Land
in dem es durchaus auch heftige
Diskussionen gibt gerade beschäftigt die
Menschen hier im Land die neuen Regeln
zur Mobilmachung wer wird eingezogen wer
bleibt wie lange an der Front also das
sind Diskussionen die hier geführt
werden und trotz allem ist die
Unterstützung oder vielleicht auch
gerade deshalb ist die Unterstützung für
die die an der Front direkt kämpfen
ungebrochen groß und zwar bei allen
Bevölkerungsgruppen aktuelle
Einschätzungen live aus Kier von unserer
ZDF Korrespondentin Anne Brühl Anne ganz
lieben Dank für deine
Zeit und damit schalten wir zurück nach
Wien dort sitzt Militärexperte Markus
Reisener für uns und auch mit ihm wollen
wir jetzt nach hakiv blicken Herr
Reisner wir haben es gerade gehört die
Russen haben da ihre Angriffe in den
letzten Tagen stark verstärkt ist da mit
einer neuen Großoffensive zu
rechnen ja das ist das was einige
Experten annehmen dass das eine
sogenannte Vorbereitungsphase ist für
den möglicherweise neue Offensive der
Russen die sich grob im Raum zwischen
Sumi das ist westlich von hakif und
hakiv bis kuupjansk also von hakiv
Richtung Osten Wasi ansprechen lässt was
hier fehlt sind wirklich die
Satellitenaufnahmen die große russische
Bereitstellung auf der russischen Seite
der Grenze zeigen so wie wir die Bilder
gesehen haben 2014 aber auch vor allem
2022 das fehlt zur Zeit es ist aber so
dass dieser intensive Beschuss durchaus
gedeutet werden kann als eine
Vorbereitungsphase für eine
möglicherweise Offensive der Russen die
die Ukraine natürlich dazu bewogen hat
und das sagen auch die ukrainischen
offiziellen hier massiv die
Verteidigungsstellungen auszubauen es
wurden also hier tausende 10000 Minen
verlegt es wurden neue
Verteidigungsstellungen angelegt in
Erwartung einer möglichen Offensive mhm
jetzt erleiten die Russen enorme
materielle Verluste und unsere Zuschauer
da bekommen wir gerade mehrere Fragen zu
reihen interessiert es wie lange
Russland diesen Verschleiß noch
durchhalten kann auf dem in oder in der
Luft im Luftraum und auch auf dem Boden
und auch wir hatten das mal in der
Recherche heute Nachmittag rausgesucht
verschiedene Militärbeobachter versuchen
das in der Ukraine zu dokumentieren
teilen ihre Erkenntnisse unter anderem
auf X und alleine äh die
Auseinandersetzung die jüngste jetzt in
der Region krinki da hätten die Ukraine
33 militärzeuge verloren die Russen 163
also da sieht man dann schon mal das
Verhältnis dass der Verschleiß der
Russen doch deutlich höher liegt
erzählen Sie es uns Herr Reißner wie
lange kann Russland das noch
durchhalten und das sind jetzt einige
Aspekte relevant die quasi wichtig sind
zum Verständnis dieser Zahlen zuerst die
Zahlen selber es ist so dass wir vor
allem hier versuchen müssen unabhängigen
Beobachtern zu folgen die versuchen zu
dokumentieren auf beiden Seiten die
Verluste ein so ein Beispiel ist die
Plattform orix und wenn Sie diese
betrachten dann sehen Sie das z.B im
Verhältnis der ausgefallenen also
beschädigten zerstörten erbeuteten
Fahrzeuge es ein Verhältnis gibt von
5000 auf ukrainischer Seite zu knapp
14.000 auf russischer Seite das heiß das
ist ein Verhältnis von
1,2 also 1 Z 2,8 das ist knapp 1 Z3 wenn
man jetzt a militärischer Sicht
betrachtet das Verhältnis dass ein
Angreifer braucht gegenüber einem
Verteidiger so ist dieses Verhältnis
ein:3 wenn der verteid er eingegraben
ist ein zu vi wenn er sich im ubanen
befindet bis zu ein Z8 das heißt die
Russen sind hier eigentlich als
Angreifer in der Norm wenn man sich
konkret einzelne Waffensysteme
heraussucht dann sieht man dass sich
auch hier die Verhältniszahlen zum Teil
nicht wesentlich verändern nehmen wir
rein die Panzerfahrzeuge so ist das 700
zerstörte beschädigte beuteete
ukrainische zu 2600 russischen so sie
dokumentiert sind das heißt eine Zahl
von 1, 1 Z 3,6 in etwa das heiß hier ist
die Zahl signifikant höher aber immer
noch auch in dieser normenzahl solange
Russland mit einem funktionierenden
militärischen industriellen komplex und
der funktioniert weil er wird ja nicht
angegriffen von der Ukraine oder es
gelingt der Ukraine kaum diese
industriellen komplexe anzugreifen
solange hier die Produktion läuft ist
Russland in der Lage nicht nur neue
Panzer z.B zu erzeugen
kampfschützenbands oder anderes sondern
vor allem auch Fahrzeuge die aus der
Zeit der Sovjet auf Haltes sind instand
zu setzen und an die Front zu bringen
gebart mit der verfügbaren Anzahl an
Soldaten gelingt es den Russen hier die
Kräfte zu näherern und das ist auch der
Grund warum die massive Steigerung der
verfügbaren Kräfte auf russischer Seite
zu beobachten war die Ukraine muss das
natürlich niederkämpfen und das ist das
Dilemma solange Russland quasi ihr immer
wieder Nachschub bringt ist es sehr
schwierig quasi hier massiv
entgegenzuhalten und eine erfolgreiche
Offensive durchzuführen so wie das
letztes Jahr intendiert war aber es
nicht dazu gekommen ist mhm und das
interessiert ein unserer Zuschauer auf
Youtube auch gerade wie viel kann
Russland an Panzern Waffen
nachproduzieren er vermutet die Russen
hätten nur eine Panzerfabrik weiter im
Osten warum greift die Ukraine nicht die
innerrussischen
transportbahnlinien an n die erste Frage
ist wie lange und wie in welchen Umfang
kann Russland hier weiterpuzieren
Russland kann sol lange weiter
produzieren solange es die Ressourcen
verfügbar hat und hier darf man nicht
vergessen dass Russland hier ja auch
signifikant unterstützt wird von Ländern
des sogenannten globalen Südens wir
wissen dass ca 60 bis 80% der
elektronischen Bauteile über China
geliefert werden wir wissen dass quasi
Indien eine nicht unresentliche Rolle
spielt und das natürlich führt dazu dass
Russland in der Lage ist seine Systeme
quasi weiter zu produzieren sie dürfen
nicht vergessen dass aus der Zeit der
Sowjetunion es immer das Ziel war vor
allem quantitäts zu produzieren und
nicht Qualität das war ein ganz anderer
Ansatz als z.B im Westen wo man z.B im
Kampfpanzer Leopard vor allem maximale
Qualität vereint hat die Russen hab
immer gesagt wir werden den Leopard im
direkten Duell nicht besiegen können
darum produzieren wir vier fün Panzer da
wird werden wir zwar drei vier verlieren
im Kampf mit diesem einzelnen Leopard
aber der vierte fünfter Panzer wird ih
dann quasi zerstören und wir versuchen
so einfach wie möglich zu bauen das heiß
der Schutz der Besatzung z.B ist nicht
relevant denn dieser eine Panzer muss
nur drei vier Schuss quasi an den Gegner
bringen also an diesen Leopard und dann
wird er zerstört im Wesentlichen das ist
der Erwartungshaltung und das führt auch
dazu dass die Russen um wenig Geld im
Vergleich zu westlichen Systemen relativ
viel bekommen also relativ viele
Fahrzeuge die ser einfach gebaut sind
und durchaus auch in diesem Gelände und
in diesen Gebieten sehr erfolgreich
eingesetzt werden können weil sie z.B
leichter sind dass die schweren
westlichen kampfahrzeuge wie z.B ein
Leopard mit über 60 Tonnen im Vergleich
zu den russischen tmodell wir schauen
heute Abend bei Z F live auf die
aktuellen Brennpunkte Herr Reisner und
Stichwort Panzer die Stadt afdfg stand
auch jetzt in den letzten Tagen in den
Schlagzeilen die Ukraine hatte hier
einen Schützenpanzer Bradley im Einsatz
der ja fleißig russische Panzer
beschossen hatte also trotz
Nachproduktion der Russen scheint es ja
nicht zu gelingen
dann doch da verschiedene ukrainische
Grenzen zu
durchbrechen n noch hier ist es wieder
so dass die Macht der Bilder was sie
ausschlaggebend ist wir sehen ein kurzes
Video wir sehen ein Teil eines
gesamtvideos in diesem Video sehen wir
einen ukrainischen kampfschützenpanzer
US-Produktion vom Typ m2 Bradley der auf
einen russischen Panzer vom Tip T90
feuert auf der einen Seite können wir
dieses ukrainische Fahrzeug zuordnen und
zwar es ist ein Fahrzeug der 47
mechanisierten Brigade jene Brigade die
vor einigen Wochen gerade zur rechten
Zeit nach aufdfk verlegt worden ist denn
sie hat mit ihren Gegenangriffen es
geschafft die russische Zangenbewegung
im Norden um die Stadt zu stoppen auf
der anderen Seite sehen wir ein Fahrzeug
der Russen ein T90 vermutlich der 90
panzerdivision die in diesem Raum
eingesetzt ist und Sie sehen wir sich
diese zwei Fahrzeuge bekämpfen der
Bradley hat das Feuer auf diesem T90
eröffnet sie sehen die Explosionen diese
Explosionen stammen von der
sprengmunition der 25 mm Kanone dieses
Bradl dann reißt das Video ab wenn Sie
das Video weiter sehen dann sehen sie
dass der russische Panzer flüchtet er
versucht sich abzusetzen in der Panik
fährt die Besatzung auf einen Baum auf
und nachdem die Ukraine auch eine
sogenannte first person vi droh eine
kamekaz Drohne auf den Panzer einsetzen
ist es so dass der Panzer im Prinzip
liegen bleibt die Besatzung absitzt und
flüchtet und das ist sehr Ausschlag
aussagekräftig denn es zeigt dass der
Beschuss des Bradleys nicht dazu geführt
hat dass der Panzer zerstört worden ist
oder die Besatzung quasi neutralisiert
worden ist sondern die Besatzung konnte
sich aufgrund des Schutzes des Panzers
weiter absetzen und erst aufgrund der
Situation des Angriff ist durch die
kamekaz Drohne waren sie gezwungen den
banzo zu verlassen und genau das gleiche
ist auch den Ukrainer passiert im Sommer
mit den leopardpanzern hier wurden auch
die Panzer beschossen die Besatzungen
konnten zwar überleben weil sich
absetzen konnten aber das Fahrzeug wurde
quasi verlassen oder musste da musste
aufgegeben werden und damit sehen wir
dass natürlich hier auch diese Bilder
ganz wichtig sind im Informationsraum
denn sie führen vor allem dazu dass sie
die Moral der eigenen Truppen stärken
und natürlich unsere Ideen unsere unser
Verständnis von diesem Konflikt quasi
entweder fördern oder natürlich prechend
stärken aber man mussich immer die
Gesamtsituation neutral betrachten und
eine Analyse durchführen um wirklich zu
wissen was ist hier passiert ist im
Wesentlichen mhm anknüpfend an die Lage
in afdfka fragt unser Zuschauer jui auf
Youtube was hat afdka für eine Bedeutung
dass Russland mit so vielen Mitteln
versucht das
einzunehmen dazu muss man wieder die
ukrainischen verteidigungsanstrengungen
verstehen die in den letzten 8 Jahren
von den Ukrainer versucht worden sind
umzusetzen also mittlerweile neun Jahren
seit 2014 es war so dass man versucht
hat quasi die sogenannten
separatistengebiete die ja nach der
minskerlinie von der russischen Seite
besetzt geblieben sind quasi
entsprechend zu zandieren und
Verteidigungslinien anzulegen hier gab
es es so im wesentlichen drei tief
gestaffelte Verteidigungslinien die
erste Linie haben die Russen letztes
Jahr durchbrochen bei propassner das hat
dann zur Schlacht von L schansonetz
geführt dann ist es gelungen auch
tatsächlich bei Solidar Richtung bakmut
vorzustoßen und diese Städte wie z.B
bakmut oder afdfka das sind wichtige
frontstädte die von den Ukrainern über
Jahre befestigt worden sind und wenn sie
fallen dann verliert die Ukraine ein
wichtigen Stützpunkt und die Russen
können weiter vorrücken das sind oft
Städte der Namen uns nicht sagen wie z.B
auch Marinka als um ein Beispiel zu
nehmen und darum ist der Kampf um diese
kleinen Städte zum Teil auch nur Dörfer
so bedeutungsvoll weil sie wichtige
Stützpunkte sind im
verteidigungspositiv Dispositiv der
Ukrainer gegenüber den russenm nun hat
eine Meldung heute Nachmittag auch
aufhuchen lassen sie ist noch nicht
unabhängig bestätigt worden aber die
Ukraine hatte wohl
zwei drohen heute nach Russland längt
und in der Region Leningrad so sagt es
zumindest die russische Seite konnten
diese abgeschossen werden eine dieser
abgeschossenen drohen hat wohl in der
Nähe von stankt petersburg ein öldepot
getroffen wie groß da der Schaden ist
das ist nicht bekannt aber es hat doch
schon aufreuchen lassen dass man jetzt
diese langen
Strecken zurücksitetzt ist das jetzt ein
strategischer Wechsel von ukrainischer
Seite weil man eben am Boden erer auf
defensive setzt nicht aktiv nach vorne
gehen kann dass man jetzt versucht aus
der Luft wirklich weit rein nach
Russland zu
fliegen ja dieser Einsatz ist
tatsächlich bemerkenswert weil die
Distanz C 1250 km betragen und die
Ukraine verfolgt mit dertigen Einsätzen
mehrere Absichten die erste Absicht ist
es auch ganz klar der russischen
Bevölkerung und zwar der relevanten
russischen Bevölkerung und das ist j in
STT petersburg und in Moskau zu zeigen
dass quasi hier ein Krieg tobt und
dieser Krieg auch vor ihre Haustüren und
in ihre Häuser getragen werden kann
darum diese Angriffe auf St Petersburg
und auch der Versuch immer wieder nach
Moskau vorzustoßen das zweite ist man
zeigt qu dass man auch hier in der Lage
ist das Momentum wieder zurückzugewinnen
trotz der Misserfolge gegen den
russischen Angriff quasi im Donbass als
Beispiel kann man also hier zeigen dass
man sehr wohl in der Lage ist das ja
prnant quasi auch tatsächlich Erfolge zu
erzielen auch wenn sie quasi nur
Einzelerfolge sind und keinen
durchschlagendes Ergebnis mit sich
bringen das dritte und auch nicht
unwesentliche ist Russland ist natürlich
gezwungen Fliegerabwehr zum Schutze auch
seiner Städte einzusetzen fliegabwerr
die möglicherweise an der Front
gebraucht wird wo sie die Ukrainer daran
hindert quasi durchstoßen zu können mit
ihren bodenboden oder luftbodensystemen
die in der Tiefe quasi der russischen
besetzten Gebiete wirken sollen das
heißt wir haben also hier mehrere
Aspekte die eine Relevanz haben und wenn
wir uns noch einmal kurz anhören was die
ukrainischen offiziellen gegen Ende des
Jahres gesagt haben so haben sie
festgestellt dass es auch das Ziel sein
wird wenn man von der Offensive jetzt in
die Defensive geht nicht nur das eigene
Land dahingehend zu konsolidieren dass
es wieder in der Lage ist quasi
Rüstungsindustrie hochzufahren sondern
auch mit entsprechenden präzisen
weitreichenden Waffensystemen Russland
zu Versuch in der Tiefe zu treffen und
damit komme ich noch mal auf die Frage
zues Hörers warum wird quasi der Ukraine
nicht warum ist es der Ukraine nicht
möglich quasi diese Fabriken quasi in
Russland anzugreifen weil sie zum Teil
diese entwickelten Waffensysteme noch
nicht produziert hat und sie auch nicht
geliefert worden sind und das versucht
die Ukraine jetzt über das nächste Jahr
über dieses Jahr zu verändern um auch
hier Russland in der Tiefe zu treffen
mit Blick auf den westlichen
Unterstützer in Sachen Waffenlieferung
der Ukraine fragt unser Zuschauer
Wladimir Huo auf Youtube sind die
Bedenken vor einer Linie bei der
Lieferung von weitreichenden Flugkörpern
nachvollziehbar falls mit Taurus
militärische Ziele im russischen
Hinterland angegriffen
werden und hier schwingt natürlich immer
mit der Umstand dass Russland ein Staat
ist der nuklear beewaffnet ist und dass
man nicht weiß was passiert wenn
Russland sich wirklich in die Enge
getrieben fühlt das ist natürlich so
nicht ausgesprochen aber es ist Fakt
woran erkennt man das indem man sich
ansieht was an Waffensystemen wirklich
geliefert wird und in welchem Umfang
Qualität und Quantität quasi geliefert
wird also denken sie z.B an heimasysteme
die wurde eine begrenzte Anzahl
geliefert aber nicht die geforderten 150
Stück quasi wie das die Ukraine
gefordert hat denken Sie an weitere
Waffensysteme von denen die Ukraine
immer wieder eine gewisse Stückzahl
bekommen hat aber nicht die
entscheidende z.B diese Army tactical
missile von denen es quasi ca 30 Stück
gab die eingesetzt worden sind sehr
erfolgreich gegen quasi russische
Flugplätze absprungplätze der russischen
Kampfhubschrauber aber damit was D auch
bewendet oder denken Sie an die diskuss
bezüglich des Taus im Wesentlichen ja
und da ist ganz klar dass im Prinzip
diese Sorge mitschwingt ob es dazu
tatsächlich kommt oder nicht das wissen
wir nicht wir erleben gerade Geschichte
und niemand kann Ihnen sagen ob eine
Entscheidung richtig oder falsch ist das
wird dann der Historiker in D Nachschau
durchführen fakt ist dass Russland mit
seinem militärisch industriellen Komplex
nach wie vor produzieren kann und die
Ukraine empfindlich treffen kann während
die Ukraine Tag für Tag den
strategischen Luftangriffen der Russen
in der tief ihres Landes ausgesetzt ist
ja und der Westen hat Probleme die USA
können gerade NS liefern die EU tut sich
schwer durch ein Veto Ungarns und da
fragt sich unser Zuschauer Martin Meer
wenn die politische Lage und die
Unterstützung des Westens so bleiben wie
sie aktuell sind welches sind dann die
wahrscheinlichsten
kriegsverlaufszenarien in den nächsten
Monaten und genau diese Entwicklung
versucht die Ukraine Rechnung zu tragen
indem sie ankündigt dass sie versucht
dieses Jahr ihren eigenen militärisch
industriellen Komplex mit ihren engen
Partner zu entwickeln um genau dieses
Manko nämlich diese äigkeit gegenüber
dem Westen zu verringern mögliche
Szenarien sind vor allem drei das erste
Szenario ist dass aufgrund des Umstandes
dass die Ukraine nicht das bekommt dass
sie braucht um sich gegen den Aggressor
zu wehren in die Defensive kommt und das
Staat zu existieren aufhört denn das ist
ja das Kriegsziel der Russen das Putin
ganz am Anfang gesagt hat das Szenario 2
wäre wenn die Ukraine schafft quasi
zumindest mit eigener Produktion
entsprechend so Waffen zu liefern und zu
zu produzieren dass man eine Art
patzsituation schaffen kann wo es auch
der russischen Seite nicht gelingt
massiv durchzustoßen und das dritte
Element wäre natürlich theoretisch auch
eine massive Unterstützung der Ukraine
durch den Westen dass es gelingen würde
tatsächlich die Russen aus dem besetzten
Gebieten zurückzudringen das erscheint
aber jetzt zur Zeit V in Anbetracht der
Lieferungen nicht realistisch und das
ist genau das Ergebnis der
Strategieentwicklung der Ukraine die
sagt dieses Jahr ist das Jahr der
Defensive das Jahr der Konsolidierung um
dann möglicherweise 2025 wieder langf
über zu gehen wenn sie genug Ressourcen
hat nicht nur an Material sondern auch V
allem Humanressourcen um hier den Russen
etwas gegen zu halten sagt der
militärxperte Oberst Markus Reisner Herr
Reisner ich danke Ihnen für das Gespräch
heute Abend bei
uns herzlichen Dank für Zeit und
Vertrauen ja und auch danke an euch da
draußen für die zahlreichen Fragen und
für das regge Interesse das war unser
Ukraine Update für diese Woche nächste
Woche gibt's das nächste und bis DAH
wünschen wir euch ja eine halbwegs gute
Zeit bis bald
[Musik]
tschüss